قبل المزاج العالمي مع مانشستر لا
القفص
فيسنتي باديلا هذا السبت قبل
متقلب
أمروك تصف أو تقتصر على الثابت
من اللمس
لا شيء لدي مع التسريبات
سنوات عديدة في هذا وآمل أن يكون
أنهم يعرفونني لا ليس لدي شك في أنني
أصدق ما أقوله عن
التسريبات ليس لدي علاقة
تهنئة للسرية لأني لا أعرف
لماذا لا اريد ان اعرف ماذا اريد
عد الناس لكنني أفضل ألا أعرف كيف
لقد حققوا لهم ما أقوله نعم
أن تلك التسجيلات هي لي وأن هؤلاء
التسجيلات ليست جديدة فهي بالفعل
المستخدمة في كتاب في عام 2015 كان ذلك
استدعاء القفز لريال مدريد هذا كل شيء
قصتي مع فريق من
التحقيق الذي حققنا فيه بالكامل
مرحلة الرئيس السابق الذي كان
رامون كالديرون ثلاث سنوات كارثية ثلاث
سنوات من الفساد ثلاث سنوات كثيرة
أشياء قبيحة داخل النادي
800 ليلة هذا ما يسميه الكتاب
ثمانمائة وليلة غريبة تعمل و
في كتاب 2015 الاعتداء على الحقيقي
ما يسمى مدريد هو كل هذا مع ما
والذي تم نشره في عام 2015 لن أفعله
مرشح في 2021 لا أعرف أين لديهم
خارج الأشرطة التي لا أعرفها
ما هو تأثير تصدع شديد
الإسراع من قبل
يبدو أنني أدركت أن نعم كان كذلك
صاحب السرية
لا علاقة لي به
سرية أعرف الناس الذين يعملون
عدد كاف من الناس الذين يعملون ولكن ليس لدي
لا علاقة للسرية
أنا لم أعمل في السرية قط ولا
ليس لدي فكرة أنني لا أعرف حقًا صدقني
حتى أن هناك أشخاصًا يعملون
العناصر الآن مع تلك التي لدي
علاقة سنوات عديدة وتحدث مع
لا يريدون معرفة أي شيء لا أفضله
أعرف ذلك لأنه نعم أعلم أنني ذاهب إليه
أشعر بالسوء وأنا أعلم أنني لن أحبه
الذي سربه من أعطاها
كيف حصلوا عليه ولكن ما هو
السخف هو أن شخصًا ما يعتقد أن الرقم 8
هذا لأنهم وبعضهم
تسجيلات من 2006 2007 إلى 2012 أو 13
لأنه لا معنى له في 21
في ريال مدريد
الحد الأدنى من القناة والجوقة التي تم إنشاؤها
في فيينا أنه قبل أن يعتمد أحد
سيكون هنالك
الحياة المؤسس المشارك لهذه المدينة
إنها مزحة أتعرف عليها وأفهمها
أن ريال مدريد متوتر للغاية
أنا أفهم أن كل هذا قد أمسك بك
غير مستعدين ليس لديهم أي فكرة
أنا أفهم أنه وابل من الثلاثاء
الأربعاء الخميس صباحا بعد الظهر مساء وأنا
أنا أفهم كل ذلك وأفهم ذلك
أول ما يخطر ببالك قول ذلك
دعونا نرى أنهم اتهموني في ذلك اليوم
نائب رئيس ريال مدريد
الرجل الثاني بعد فلورنتين
بيريز أني في العام 2011 في العام
2011 في وجبة طلبت منه 10 ملايين
لتلك التسجيلات التي سنراها في
2011 كنت أعمل كـ
مدير الرياضة في وسائل الإعلام
اتصال مهم في اسبانيا لي
كنت أتعامل مع realmadrid يوميًا
فلورنتينو بيريز مع اللاعبين
لأنني سأتحدث معه
نائب الرئيس ولكن ما لا يفهمه
لا أحد في إسبانيا أن الجريمة ليست كذلك
الألغام هي الجريمة نائب الرئيس ، نعم
كان ذلك صحيحًا لدى نائب الرئيس
بعد أن ذهب إلى المحكمة يجب أن تفتح
إلى الشرطة كان يجب أن أذهب إلى
الإعلام وأدين نفسي
واصل العمل مع ريال مدريد-
وقت طويل في الواقع هناك الكثير
التسجيلات بعد التاريخ
يقول أنه قابلني ولن يرغب أحد
لقد صدق ذلك وأعتقد أنه قليل
أول ما حدث لهم أن يغادروا
في الجنون الذي نعيشه
في إسبانيا ولكن لا أحد لديه
متأملة باستثناء ريال مدريد - وهو
ارتكب الخطأ لأول مرة على الإطلاق
حياتك في استخدام حساب الشبكة الخاص بك
الاجتماعي ليقول ما وسيلة
قال الاتصال هذا عن قصد ولكن
حسنًا ، أصر سيداتي على فهم ذلك
عندما يكون الناس متوترين عندما لا يكونون كذلك
يعرفون ما يحدث وهم قليلون
مثل الملاكمين قليلاً في غير محله
حسنًا ، أفهم أن على المرء أن يقول ماذا
أول ما يتبادر إلى الذهن ولكن لا شيء
إنه أمر سخيف ، ليس أنه كذبة لا
إنها كذبة لكنها ليست كذلك
إحساس
والش الشريان بين العصبة والمادية
مدريد
يطلق عليه أن تأتي هذه القدرة
لا لا لا لا تقنيًا لن أقوم بذلك
وضع طلب تقني بين ما
يسمى فعل التوفيق في
احكم على الشخص الذي أخبرك به ، يا سيادة القاضي ، اتصل بك
لهؤلاء السادة الذين يأتون ويعلمونه
الاختبارات إذا لم يكن لديهم اختبارات لا يفعلون ذلك
لديهم دليل إذا كانوا قد اخترعوه
أنهم اخترعوه جيدًا سنرى ماذا
سنفعل إذا كان هناك اتهام لا
أعرف لأنني أفهمهم حقًا
أنا أفهم أنهم كلهم
العيش فوق قوته وهو
معقدة وبصرف النظر هنا العدالة
بطيئة جدا عندما يحين الوقت
لتقرر لأنه قبل ذلك لا يمكنك إذا
أستنكر ريال مدريد لذلك
اتهام لا لريال مدريد لا أبدا
لن يكون ريال مدريد أبدًا هو الأفضل
قال لشخص بالاسم واللقب
حسنًا ، سيكون في غضون ستة أشهر أو 78
لا أعرف ، لا ، لكني أصر على أنه لم يفعل
تتأثر لأن الآخرين
يبدو أن الأخبار المضحكة هي أنك
المتهم بجريمة تنص على
خمس سنوات أنهم يتهمونك بإحدى عشرة سنة
ثم يتم عمل نكتة
جيمس والأمام مع جلد الغزال أقوى
منافسي فريق اختبار السيدات
منافسة
أفضل مما يسمى
الصناعات
دعونا نرى بصراحة لا أعرف ولكن
لقد سئلت عدة مرات في
هذه الساعات الماضية وأنا أقول لك ذلك
فلورنتينو بيريز هو أحد الرجال
نعم ، الأهم في عالم كرة القدم
لكنه أحد رواد الأعمال في
أكبر بناء في العالم
عالم العالم وما فلورنتينو بيريز
تعمل كرة القدم في العديد من البيئات
شركات المقاولات الكبيرة و
لن يكون لفلورنتين أعداء فقط
في كرة القدم كما أضعها في داخلي
عدو المهنة منذ فلورنسا
العديد من الأعداء في العديد من الأماكن و
العديد من الأصدقاء أيضًا
حالة فلورنتينو صعبة للغاية
فكر من أين يأتي هذا
فلورنتينو أو ريال مدريد من أين
قد تكون شركة منافسة
لك في شيلي أو في كندا أو في ألمانيا
أو في اليابان أو في المملكة العربية السعودية أو في
الإمارات يمكن أن تكون شريكًا
غاضب منه لا أعلم إن كان هناك
لديه شركاء غاضبون ولكن يمكن أن يكونوا كذلك
أكثر بكثير من شخص واحد
عادي
لأنه بصرف النظر عما خرج فهو من
الأهمية المتعالية قد ظهرت فيها
كل البلدان التي لم أرها من قبل
الكثير من اللغات
نشر اسمي ولكنه ليس كذلك
مهم ، أي أنه ليس متسامياً ، يجب أن يكون
هناك أشياء أكثر أهمية بكثير
أهم بكثير للتنزيل الجغرافي
الضرورة
لآلاف الأسباب أولاً لأن أياً منهما
نحن في تحقيق فيها
على سبيل المثال ، في عام 2007 كان عمري 260 عامًا
أيام في المحكمة بالنسبة لي من العمر
وضعني رئيس ريال مدريد لي 33 o
34 شكوى مع طلب حبس
طلب جميع أصولي من
أطفالي بالطبع كنت سأذهب
المحاكم في الصباح وفي
في وقت متأخر كل يوم لذلك أنا
طلبت المحكمة 12 شيئًا آخر
نفس الشيء في المحكمة 32 نفس الشيء
محكمة 27 وبدأت شيئًا لم أفعله
كان لدي صحيفة في المدرسة أو عندما كنت
الشباب ولكن لديهم مذكرات
لكتابة كل ما قاله في
حكم إلى الأبد يقول نفس أعطى
دعونا نرى ما إذا كنت سأرتكب خطأ وبعد ذلك
لا بد لي من تسجيل كل شيء
فعلت هذا كل ما فعلناه
نحن نلعب لم تكن وظيفة
الصحفي الذي كان أول نعم ولكن
كان من الممكن ارتكاب خطأ
تفاصيل صغيرة وينتهي به الأمر في السجن
لذلك أردت إعادة تأكيد كل شيء
ما كان
لم اكن هناك شيء مهم جدا
أريد أن يكون الأمر واضحًا جدًا ، لا أفعل
كان أحد الأصدقاء يسجل هذا ليس اثنين
الأصدقاء يتناولون الويسكي عند الساعة الثانية
الصباح لست رئيس الحقيقي
مدريد تراه 24 ساعة في اليوم و
كنت رئيس الرياضة للوسيط
الاتصال مهم جدا وكان
24 ساعة في اليوم وسبعة أيام أ
أسبوع
هذا ليس
صديقان أو شقيقان يتحدثان معي
من الأشياء لا لا هذا لا يختلف لا لا
لا تخلط بينه وبين ليس هناك جين
من روح غرانيا مع بيريز من
الناس لا لا هنا في إسبانيا الآن هم
كثير ممن خرجوا بوسائل كثيرة
العديد من مراسلينا
سيعرفون بقولهم ما إذا كنا جميعًا نعرف ذلك و
هو أن فلورنتينو هكذا أقول لك 12 14
قالت وسائل الإعلام ذلك
أربعة أيام الماضية من الميكروفونات
قبالة الكاميرا فلورنتينو ذلك
قال الكثير الآن هذه الأيام
عديدة
المحرر السابق لإحدى الصحف
مهم جدا لصحيفة واحدة من
أهم المشاريع الرياضية في
المدير القديم
يقولون أنه كتب دعونا نذهب في ذلك اليوم
لا أعرف ما إذا كان هو أم كتبه شخص آخر
أن موسيقى الجاز عرفت كل ذلك بسبب
لقد سمع فلورنتينو كل ذلك
لقد انجرفوا بالفعل في فحص السخرية
توقف عن الاهتمام بيريز ونفس النار
وقتل من ممارسة الهواء لي واحد
تفقد أي محرك يفصلنا عنك
لدي 7000 8000 كيلومتر وأنت
أستطيع أن أقول سبعة آلاف مرة أقسم
لا أعلم أنني لا أعرف ولكن الأسوأ
يا رجل هناك شيء واحد سأخبرك به
أنا لا أغطي أو أخفي نفسي وأنا
اتصلوا وأنا هنا سأذهب
كل المواقع التي تتصل بي
لقد نشرت كتابا به كل هذا
2015 كتاب لم يعجبه فلورنتينو
وتأكدت من أن المكتبات
سيقومون بإزالته وإعادته و
سوف تختفي ، حسنًا ، هذه هي القواعد
من اللعبة ولكن هذا كل هذا بالفعل
تم كتابته في عام 2015
حتى الآن لا أعرف لماذا
لا أحد ينقذك من ماراثون القراءة
فلورنتينو بيريز للمجتمع وريجينا
الكهربائية في وسط المساواة القصوى
الذي جعل هذا الليمون قد أصلح
يمنعني القانون والقانون من أن أكون انتقائيًا
القلب وكذلك هو المخترق وفلورنتينو
تحمل بيريز
وإلغاء المزيد المرسلة
andy 16 لعلامات الإحالة إلى
كهربة البريد العشوائي والجير
خارج المياه المحرك أكثر
تقني
دعونا نرى كل شيء لديه ما يسمى
تناسب فلورنتينو بيريز
من يترأس النادي الرياضي
مهمة كبيرة ومعترف بها في العالم
لديه هوس لا يمكن أن يكون
هاجس السيطرة على جميع وسائل الإعلام
كل الوسائط من حولك
ولكن هناك مدينة في اسبانيا
مثال يسمى إشبيلية لأن
رئيس إشبيلية يريد السيطرة
وسائل الإعلام الصغيرة لإشبيلية للجميع
رؤساء جميع فرق
كرة القدم تريد السيطرة على البيئة
وسائل الإعلام تريد ألا يخطئ الجميع
كل ذلك دون استثناء وفي إسبانيا بالنسبة لي
إنه لأمر مؤلم أن أخبرك لأنه ربما يرى
ما رأيته في سني يجب أن يكون
اختار مسارًا آخر حتى لو لم يكن هناك
لا يمكن إلا في إسبانيا أكثر من 80 في المئة
مائة
شركة رياضية تعمل تحت الأوامر
من كبار المديرين التنفيذيين من القادة
رياضات مهمة
بيريز
لأنني الآن لا أعرف
أربع مرات لا أعرف حتى من
لقد تسربت أصر على أن عمري 40 عامًا
41 عامًا في الراديو في إسبانيا وأنا لا أفعل ذلك
إنهم يعرفون الكذب الذي لم أخسره
أبدا محاكمة لم أقلها من قبل
كذبة لم اتهم من قبل بالكذب
أبدا في حياتي لا أعرف ما الذي لديه
لا أعرف لماذا الآن ومتى
لقد سربوا هذا الجزء الذي لا أستطيع
الجواب لأني أقسم أنني لا أعرف و
الآخر لأنها سجلت لأنني سجلت
في محادثاتي مع فلورنتينو
بيريز أو مع أي شخص أنا معه
يكون عاملا لأنهم
لديهم السلك
وكنا فريقًا من الأشخاص
كنا نلعب في السجن بسبب
عادة كنا آخر واحد لم نعد
كان هناك المزيد لم يعد هناك المزيد من الصحافة
من البحث الذي اكتشفناه
أبشع الأشياء في كل فريق كرة قدم
القادة الذين أخذوا المال
السياسيين رشاهم
المديرين التنفيذيين من الاتحادات
رياضة كرة القدم كرة السلة لأولئك الذين
لقد رشوا أو رشوا بعد ذلك
عندما يكون هذا كل ما تفعله
أيام يجب أن تكون واضحا جدا أن ما كنت
تقول أنه يمكنك إثبات أن هذا هو
السبب لا يوجد أكثر
من ميلانو يرسم الجير ويرسله إلى دي
كرة القدم
الإعلان أيضا عن الماء غير اللامع لذلك من
التحرير والقانون الذي يجعلك تحضر
كتلة حبل التطريز ذلك
منشار
كالعادة ، لا شيء يؤثر علي
أنا قلق للغاية بشأن عائلتي ، زوجتي
أطفالي أنه في كل مرة يذهب
التأثير أقل سأخبرك بواحد
حكاية في نوفمبر 2007 جاءت أ
يهدد صديقًا عزيزًا سالمًا من اختراعه
حاولوا قتلي مرتين أو ثلاث مرات
ولكن جاء ذلك تهديد خطير للغاية
يتصل بمحكمة في إسبانيا أن بلدي
يتعرض الأطفال للاضطهاد الثلاثة
كان لدي ثلاثة أطفال ، أحدهم 18 عامًا والآخر 16.
وآخر 6
كان لا بد من إزالتها من ليلة الخميس
ماذا حدث في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) 2007؟
إلى السبت من الخميس إلى السبت اضطررت إلى ذلك
اصطحب كل من أطفالي إلى
قارة أخرى غير بلد
مختلف ولا أعرف أين
هل أخبرتك بهذا لأنه إذا كان الأمر كذلك
السابع في عام 2021 يؤثر عليهم لكنه يؤثر عليهم
أقل بكثير وبصرف النظر ليس في
إسبانيا اتهموني أو أدخلوني
هذا اليوم الأول
الآن اليوم على سبيل المثال لا يوجد أحد لي
لم أقرأ أي شيء أو لم تجدني
لا شيء يقول أنني أقوم بالتصفية لأنني
قلت في اليوم الأول عدم التصفية لأن
لقد قلتها في كل الأماكن التي قلتها
سأل ولماذا لا أحد
هناك سبب لماذا لا ترى
فلترني نعم نعم انا لست مضحك 21
سنوات لأنني سأقوم بترشيحها بسبب
لم أفعل ذلك قبل أن يكون الأمر سخيفًا
الحقيقة ليس لها قدم ولا رأس
والليل
لقد جئت على ما لدي
الملف هناك أكثر من ذلك بكثير ولكن لا أعرف ماذا
الذي لديه السرية أخشى
أخشى ما أراه بالترتيب الذي
إنهم يزيلونه أنه يجب عليهم الانتهاء منه
من أعطاها للسرية
أعطى الجزء الرياضي للجزء
لاعب كرة القدم
المهم أن هناك حتى في الخاص بك
البلد الذي تعرفه
أعتقد أنني أؤمن بسبب ما أقرأه
كقارئ أو متفرج
أكثر أعتقد أن هذا ما استطاعوا
لدي كل ما لا أعرفه
إمكانية الوصول إلى لعبتك في
يداي
لم يخرج أي شيء مهم
لا شيء مطلقا
[موسيقى]
نعم ، لكنني بدأت أفكر أيضًا
اليوم الرابع من هذه الرواية أن
السرية لا تملكها ، أعتقد ذلك ، لكن
إذا جاء المزيد أقول لك انظر أنني كنت مخطئا لا
أنا أعرف
لأنهم يأخذون الأفضل فقط
استراتيجيته هي أن تبدأ
لاعبي كرة القدم ثم يحصلون على المزيد من الأشياء أقسم
لا أعرف حتى من الذي لديه
ولا ما أعطاه
وابل وايزن للسحر المحمي
من الطالب خوسيه يجب أن يمسكه
سنوات فيزيائي وهو أيضا قتل أكثر
إذا كانت هناك عدة أشياء من ناحية أخرى
كثير منهم في الكتاب أن
2015 كتاب على سبيل المثال في الواقع
مدريد هناك شيء مقدس تقريبا لا
بنفس القدر ولكن تقريبًا مقدسًا مثل
القرآن أو مثل الكتاب المقدس الذي هو القائمة
من المشتركين في النادي قائمة
انتظار مشتركي النادي خطيئة
تخطي تلك القائمة هناك أشخاص ينتظرون
8 سنوات 10 سنوات 11 سنة 15 سنة وهناك
القائمة التي يتم اتباعها حقًا
بدقة يجب أن يكون مثل هذا
إنها كذبة ، كان هناك مدراء
أمروا سلالة
ويضع شعبه أصدقاء سياسيين
رجال الأعمال على القائمة تخطي
طلب هذا أيا كان
المديرين والذين تم تعيينهم من قبل
الباب الخلفي على سبيل المثال أن ذلك
سيكون بالنسبة لي أكثر بدانة من كل شيء
ما تم نشره الآن على أرض الواقع
مدريد
أناس من ريال مدريد - قريبون من ريال مدريد
مدريد ليست المؤسسة التي أعتبرها دائمًا
المؤسسة بأسماء و
ألقاب ريال مدريد- شارك
في عملية احتيال حماية الأرضيات
الرسمية أنها شقق تصنعها الدولة
المنازل التي تمنحها لها الدولة
الناس في حاجة رخيصة جدا
حسنًا ، تلك المنازل لم تذهب إليها
ذهب المحتاجين إلى أطفال
رجال الأعمال لأبناء المديرين
أطفال لاعبي كرة القدم أو لاعبي كرة القدم للأطفال
من الصحفيين والصحفيين ذات الصلة
هذا هو النظام أيضا
مر ريال مدريد بوقت مضطرب
لنقل النقود السوداء
أعتقد أنه نقل المال الأسود
أؤكد أنني أؤمن بذلك في الملاذات الضريبية و
تزوير مبيعات التذاكر
يخدعون الدولة الإسبانية وينتصرون
الغش في الاتحاد الأوروبي لكرة القدم هذا أيضًا
كم من المال وكيف وكيف
لقد فعلوا
كانت هناك
قبل
وهذا كل شيء
أن تكون الفتاة المناسبة حق المساواة
لتحديد ماذا
ولم أفقد أي شيء في الكتاب
لقد صنعوا 20000 كتاب وأنا من الرفاهية
التي يمكنني تحملها وبيعوها
كثير ، أقل بكثير مني
أعتقد أنه كان من الممكن بيعها ولكن
لا أعتقد أن إعلان واحد
صحيفة ولا تلفزيون واحد ولا أ
فقط راديو لم يعلن عنه أحد لأنه
فلورنتينو نهى عن الإعلان عنها
لا بأس أنا أفهم أنني سأفعل
ربما نفس الشيء لا أعرف ذلك من ناحية
من ناحية أخرى جودة الكتاب
مثير للكتاب هو عمل
الصحفي يبدو لي أحد أكثر
رائعة بصرف النظر عن ذلك
أنا مع فريق من أكثر الناس
لامعة لقد مر وقت طويل
والكتاب الذي يقدمه رائع
مثيرة لأن لا أحد لديه شيء
لنرى بصرف النظر عن كتاب 2015 ذلك
لقد نسيت الكتاب ، انظر إلي
يقولون كل يوم لدي
عروض مهمة جدا
لإعادة نشر الكتاب وقلت
كل هذا لا لأن الشيء الوحيد المفقود
هو أنهم يقولون ذلك ما أريده الآن
إخراج الكتاب مرة أخرى لن يخرج
كتاب